director Zack Snider has a passionate
online fan base who eagerly eats up
anything he puts in front of them
critics are less kind with many dinging
the director for his chronic
self-seriousness and affinity for melod
drama and it seems like his latest
project Rebel Moon part one a child of
fire will be no different First
Reactions to what effectively amounts to
Snider's take on Star Wars have begun
pouring in on social media while there
are some bright spots many viewers took
the opportunity to dunk on the film Mark
Cassidy of the RO credits podcast didn't
mince words on X writing I wish I could
say that I loved or even liked Rebel
moon but after a promising First Act it
launches itself off a cliff Zack Snyder
is more concerned with cool action
scenes than establishing and ensuring
we're invested in his characters mlia of
next best picture had a similar opinion
posting Zack Snider's clunky execution
makes even the most basic drama feel
tedious derivative sci-fi with
unimpressive slow-mo action and dull
characters we are Beyond Redemption it
appears Rebel Moon may not win over any
prior Snider haters as it seems to
indulge in the director's most
polarizing Tendencies these reactions
also make an inauspicious beginning for
what supposed to be a new franchise with
many Rebel Moon spin-offs already
planned perhaps no one was more critical
than Eric Italiano from bro Bible who
wrote on X Rebel moon is the first movie
I've walked out of in a long long time a
stunning Dar of drama aggressive
overdirection and bad acting throughout
those First Reactions were a Troublesome
sign of what was to come reviews have
begun trickling into Rotten Tomatoes
with the first installment of Rebel Moon
currently standing at a 26% positive
rating with nearly 40 reviews that
number will undoubtedly change as more
reviews come in but it's clear Snider
movies remain as polarizing as ever
alist Ryder reviewed Rebel moon for
Looper and was much more forgiving than
many other critics giving the film a
final score of 6 out of 10 he mentioned
how like Star Wars it was obviously
influenced by kurosawa's Seven Samurai
but that's not a bad thing perhaps the
biggest Triumph of Rebel moon is that
despite wearing its biggest genre
influence proudly on its sleeve and
mimicking many of its trademarks it
never feels derivative of it however he
also criticized the film for his use of
sexual violence an unfortunate trademark
in Snider's filmography Jeremy Mai was
far less forgiving on slash film he
rated Rebel Moon four out of 10 and
thought the movie collapsed under its
own weight writing ultimately Rebel Moon
resembles little more than a grab bag
collection of worldbuilding influences
mythology and epic storytelling that
we've seen done better many times before
so the first reactions to Rebel Moon
could generously be described as mixed
but some critics seem to have enjoyed
the sci-fi flick we might stand a chance
that's the case of Molly Edwards of
total film who tweeted okay Rebel moon
is quite simply epic massive scale
beautiful visuals of course awesome
action and some really fascinating
mythology Rebel Moon part two the scar
Giver will be released on Netflix on
April 19th 2024 and this first movie
seemed to do a lot of the heavy lifting
in terms of World building to get the
sequel story where it needs to be
however it's not just a sequel that
people are looking forward to for a more
satisfying character-driven tale there's
also the coveted are rated director's
cut of the first film which has already
been confirmed many critics view the
version of Rebel Moon they saw as an
appetizer and they're just waiting for
the main course that's the case for
Joseph deel of scream rant who wrote on
X I loved the action in Rebel Moon and
This brilliant International cast but I
wish we spent more time with the rebel
recruits Zack Snider's director's cut is
a version I
[Music]
want